memes memes memes memes that's what
we're doing today you guessed it Ken
we're looking at memes you know what
that do you know what a mem me have you
heard of these oh it's I heard it
pronounced Mimi one
time ah my audience is too young to
understand these
jokes I saw such a good one this morning
it's Swedish related but it's it's
beautiful okay I'll read it for you so
you get the authentic Swedish
experience okay be at a Swedish ship
cruise haven't defecated in a week oh
week a week week at least three giant
python in the toilet try to flush not
working oh no oh no Panic try to flush
again but she doesn't flush look for
cleaner lady in the hallway Swedish is
really bad so grab the hand of cleaner
and take her to the
bathroom try try to flush and say ta
that means watch in English while push
flush button sh goes quite normally
away oh gosh go makes even more funnier
because you find it so
funny watch
this great I thought youd give me a
flash back like your golden you know the
Golden Age Of The Swedish Thing I guess
to just like expose
your ta ta look at
it how do you explain that afterwards we
can't speak Swedish either oh man it's
beautiful I I guess it's funny to me
because I feel like I could do this I
thought have done
this you know what probably I love the
word ta too that's so good Tito is a
good word I never thought of that
there's like a thing with offensive Ikea
names yeah yeah there you go SL yeah the
salute yeah can't we call that dum
buys dumb boys what does that mean ises
that literally mean like closet or
something it doesn't mean anything oh it
doesn't I thought they just were Swedish
words of like couch and stuff like that
like down there stink lover stink lover
stink
lover
I would never have thought of that no
wonder these poor Swedish people didn't
think of that who the r stank Clover
fuing Americas man ruining everything
back to the memes memes I have such baby
brain I don't remember which ones I
watch but I think you'll appreciate this
one oopsie almost missed my turn whoops
better stop in the middle of the road
yeah and then be surprised after they oh
yeah well I'm just going to keep going
God man that truck dodged it so well it
still did it just give up what are you
doing and they drove off like nothing
happened there's a flipped over truck
and one jack knife oh my god dude anyway
I have appointment I have to go byebye
oh don't hit me oh just wait my turn
that 90-year-old woman in the air his
doctor told not to drive oh God first
truck should have finished the job I
like this meme not NE neily because of
the meme itself but because Snoop Dog is
posting memes on Instagram have you
heard about this yeah Snoop been poting
memes for a while but yeah I didn't know
that I was so conf I watched his meme
I'm like what the is Snoop Dog posting
this
[__] why is Snoop Dog a
m he's good
me what else did they throw at
him amig
[Laughter]
I don't know what he's saying but I'm
motivated he just keeps getting back up
good Lord feel better someh what a
champion what the did I save this for oh
okay baby I'm
[Music]
sorry but I never me we can't laugh too
hard at this one k that's right can't uh
can't do it oh you know you no never
mind nope never mind let just keep
moving can it's too dangerous boo happy
Halloween my fellow Gamers celebrating
this year with
gfuel if you haven't tasted G fuel you
haven't tasted the Fountain of Youth The
Forbidden Elixir or also the really good
drinky I'm actually drinking it it's
inside a lot of commercials they fake it
I'm actually
look never waste a drop celebrating
Halloween with BOGO Benny or Gary
or what does it stand for I don't get it
but you buy one and then you get one
that's what it does at least BOGO sale
is the greatest sale and you're in luck
cuz PewDiePie flavor included the
greatest flavor ever invented I'm not
making this up so it's the perfect time
to stock up on your g- fuel supply or a
drink just drink it I love g-fuel energy
it's been a lifesaver especially as a
new
dad thank God for gfuel it gives you
that nice energy high without that crash
afterwards or that jittery feeling at
least for me and I love it I've been
drinking it for years it's so tasty it's
so tasty and refreshing I wish they have
it everywhere in Japan but you know I
can buy it online with my BOGO sale
there's also some fun Halloween flavors
involved with the Boger sales great time
to try out different flavors see which
one is the best one for you Ling and
Berry PewDiePie flavor don't make me
jump scare you again we got candy corn a
true
polarizer Resident Evil for last plagas
flavor tasting like pons sour gummy
worms a fan favorite a Halloween editing
reskin of our classic blue ice hype
sauce those are great and watermelon
lemonade flavor I can't read without
classes so be sure to enter the code
PewDiePie you are welcome butti more I
jump scared you a little bit some of you
got scared if you want to try out a
bunch of different flavors like a a lot
I don't want to swore but aing Tong you
can get the 15 serving mini tub you get
tub and 15 mini servings perfect for
those of you who want to try out a a
bunch of bangalo bees you don't want to
get the whole tub maybe for whatever
reason I don't understand why you
wouldn't these are available for $19.99
but inode PewDiePie you get 20% you get
20% off in case you couldn't hear that's
it thank you g for sponsoring this video
was I out of focus the whole [__]
time that adds to the
spookiness process I don't want
it ma'am that is an 11 lb whole slab of
deli ham it has no bones fat or
connective tissue it is an amalgamation
of the meat of several pigs emulsified
liquefied strained and ultimately
inexorably joined in an Unholy meat
Obelisk God had no hand in the creation
of this abhor the fact that this hand
monolith exists proves that God is
either impotent to alter his universe or
ignorant to the horrors taking place in
his kingdom this prism of pork is more
than deli meat it is a physical
Declaration of Mankind's contempt for
the natural order it is hubris manifest
we also have a lower sodium variety if
you would prefer that Jesus it's
beautiful it's some beautiful beautiful
written I got to say do you think that's
processed nah it's p n it's good you
know it's organic this has to be an
American invention what that the ham
yeah well the whatever that the meat
Obelisk I don't know if I've ever even
seen that except for like in a can you
worked on a butcher yeah I know I I did
work in a butcher we didn't have that
because cut meat on bisks we didn't we
didn't have the meat amalgamation of
whatever he said no no we didn't have
that no what did you do well we took
like the actual cuts from the animal and
then chopped it up disgusting I don't
want that I want the proc hand okay you
want you want the spam I got you I see
it here in Japan people eat it I don't
know why people eat it like like look
look theit over there oh my God it
doesn't look that bad I would eat it it
doesn't look that bad spam suit bro is
it just fake me or bro get me out of
here I don't know what it's man nobody
questions what spam is then why does it
exist look at it he just open it's just
meat in a can it's like the can have you
seen the canned chickens no oh my god
dude canned chicken that's not too bad
it look up can whole chicken hell
yeah hell yeah caned hold chicken my my
my sweet s whole can kitchen disgusting
they literally just like put chickens in
there they don't even kill them they
just come out like
that they went in
alive what the this is American
invention Sweden invent beautiful things
like superer first aid kit and other
things meanwhile America we have a
politician who apparently he created the
internet and we got CLE chicken too yeah
well done well done can someone please
explain to me why your baby always knows
when you were
home the baby knows when they come home
magically at my
house it's like how you said how like
people think their child is like genius
they like project that they're really
smart how does she know it's
crazy
oh that that that was good yeah they're
hilarious she minding hers oh my God he
me no let go of me I can do it
myself I started to feel like there's
like a theme with all my memes and I
don't know if I should keep GR in this I
didn't realize until
now I can do it
myself honestly I feel like that's kind
of a theme with a lot of people where
they think they can do do stuff and they
just can't do it like I'm definitely one
of those absolutely even like I don't
know having good form on a pullup to
where you can you can't do it you'll
fail right and you go you get down and
go oh man I can't do it but to the point
to where you like fall on your face on
the
floor embarrassing you know someone ask
you like how many push-ups can you do
and you're like I don't know 20
something 300 yeah easy yeah no but yeah
but then they're like oh yeah I can do
50 and I'm looking at them like okay I
know you can't do 50 you just trying to
one up me what do you do what do you
mean get down and do them man let's see
it hey show me your form
bro I don't want to see
it it's just not why not you stupid
imagine civilization if we had this it's
just not why not stupid imagine if a
bathtub had this that would be the most
beautiful thing what's stopping you man
you know you don't need it to be cut out
like that to fit you know what I
definitely peed in a sink and so heav
you can I will not accept any other
answer you peed in the sink just admit
it all right look not not that not this
is not that I have or anything but there
come a time in life when wife or
somebody the kids are in the bathroom
and they won't come out and you just you
got to go sometimes you just got to flop
it out and let it go and then you have
that that moment of like why can't I use
the
sink then you turn the poset on and you
go you know that's right why should I
not yeah
why it's like why is me getting in the
shower letting it go in there weird like
come on leave me alone
e you pay in the shower of course not
e disgusting you poop in the
shower I would
never never how dare I I'm sorry I
apologize moving on oh no uh
oh Fu why I why did I sa
this
he's oosha certified he's going to lose
his forklift license real face wa right
there's more forklift oh forklift on
forklift
action
oh they clearly tried I thought it was a
joke like they were just meing they're
no they're like no actually we're doing
this absolutely yeah yeah yeah just put
the forklift on the
forklift and then a forklift on that
forklift and then until we hit the moon
did they take the whole window out of
the building what yes so we can forklift
our forklift it's going to be awesome
bro so cool this is China yeah yeah I
have a lot of climbing memes I I don't
expect you to get
them oh
God someone cooked
here that's a there's a random Rock
somewhere someone just started climbing
it for no
reason it's kind of like like one of
those things where once you start
climbing you start looking at everything
like you're just like oh
yeah good crimp on this one right here
yeah no that's good I can climb that
started holding Mar's hand through the
fingertip just like yeah I got pretty
good strength there I like how the the
spots where he's holding they always
start so low too why like you have to
like get down on the ground to start off
where they start is that just to like
challenge yourself what was that about
yeah I mean yeah it's the whole sequence
yeah why can't you just you know just
jump and like half the job is already
done why don't you just go
up yeah that's what I'm saying yeah well
you got to transition to the hole you
just ruined you're just ruined Bing for
everyone I'm sorry
sorry you go ahead and take a little
glance that again as it keep going
around
PlayStation no
okay play
hey we're going
to was he going to play on that thing
Spider-Man I guess the only the only
game that's been carry in the
PlayStation 5 this entire time there's
nothing on there that's worth owning a
PlayStation is what I'm getting at so
that Meme is back after all these years
it's back
again after all these years still
PlayStation never had any games at all
yeah at Le you all play Dark Souls but
they're not even exclusive Demon Souls
is that an ick man man got
hurt I love the
caption ew This is why guys have to
pretend they never get injured so that
females won't have i at them yeah he got
hurt and cried bled gross oh more
climbing memes for you Ken oh yeah yeah
[Music]
all
these all these P that's peasants these
know how to climb a V3 let me show them
my dream is that all my friends who's
never climbed ever will just all of a
sudden in unison want to climb with me
and I get to go yeah check this out
check oh yeah have you seen
this
[Music]
he's F glad we could have a Russian
Russia update been a while been a while
I was wondering I thought for sure he
was dead yeah what the that's so high
well they say that when you're drunk
driving you know the the the drunk
person usually survives and they're
probably on all the Vodka right
now got multiple angles
simple physics you could have known this
is not going to work with a lot faster
than that to make that
jump it's not even
close how do you get the car up there I
don't know so confused got to try it
again not the environment list we need
but the Environ list we deserve
everything on me was found inside the
stomachs of sea turtles so sad oh God so
sad don't care give me back my plastic
straws now dude don't oh my God don't
get me started on
these paper straws it's what has Turtles
ever done for me nothing nothing you get
like a plastic cup that came wrapped in
plastic but your straw that also was
delivered in plastic is paper and it
dissolves it sticks to your lips when
you try to use it it's the dumbest thing
whole planet give me my microplastics
even as an epic pescatarian I will eat a
turtle to prove this point how did she
get the things out the turtle stomachs
did they go murder the turtles to get
these for her probably no I think the
plastic killed him at I think that was
oh sad so
sad more more climbing memes before you
do the dream come true for us it's your
dream you can't force a dream onto
someone else Dad yes I can I can force a
dream on you why are you yelling because
it's a good
dream it's going to be me and be in a
couple years for sure well in our new
house Mary actually wants to put these
on the wall in the kids playroom yeah I
mean kids love climbing they love it if
y doesn't love climbing put them back
what about surfing what happened to
surfing oh that too yeah for sure okay
check out this awesome 3D print that I
printed you might be
wondering make some useful like a butt
plug check out this that's what I
thought it was at
first that's still cool though what do
you mean it's a cool sword yeah so cool
you might be wondering look at that bam
I'm curious what you think of this
mean okay sorry the context is this is a
an escape room uh Place mhm so this
guy
that's the instructions on how to get
[Music]
[Laughter]
out oh God this is very controversial
how can people defend this guy if I'm at
work and someone locks the door from the
asset and says just a prank I lose my
[__] and call the cop what yeah but it's
funny it is funny and also if it's who
who is the person trying to get out or
they work there are they they pay for
the escape room and it's part of the
experience you know like what going
clearly it was the person that work
there oh it's got a block on there too I
see to me it's funny but maybe I'm
missing something I think it's funny too
cuz even it's probably just made for the
meme and he came back and let him out
anyway so he Mak mad about it not like
it's real this is something that is real
all and you you could hardly believe it
[Music]
Ken
ah took me a minute but
um yeah that's still a nice watch that's
a watch that's that's a wrist watch ah
going to hell that's really why I put
you on
here why is it all women I don't know
I'm
sorry
[Music]
it's not funny Kim I'm not laughing no
not funny I'm getting concerned for my
feed now I didn't realize need to talk
about something what's going on you got
a lot of
anger unrelated
unrelated smash it oh
yeah is that spam that's spam spam it's
bad I know it's in Japan I should try it
that's an epic
[Music]
pescetarian no
chance no no shot no
shot no
God
Jesus hell
[Applause]
[Music]
yeah
God Godlike chin beautiful wow that's
impressive the watermelon I can do that
you can do that no no
way got to start working on my
jawline
[Music]
this is me in my last video I tried to
Sue it's hard it didn't work out well
no I would love to hear about it tell me
more Mary I love to hear about it it's
so this world this world we live in
today is a pretty strange world
too
that's me being a teenager right
there it's all coming back it's all
coming back I finally wait long enough
to everyone's quiet enough where I can
say my joke and I do and they all just
kind of keep talking and I'm
like especially I I feel like yeah if I
say a joke it's funny all right I need
to laugh oh I love M jokes yeah they're
the best how can you not laugh they must
have not heard me I better tell them
again it's the only explanation why they
didn't laugh look at that Gator that's H
you're literally just swimming here
earlier
that's Is that real no no it's not real
why
not oh you want it to be you want that
to be real yeah this is a rock it's just
a rock I got it yeah I would scream a
bit I would scream a bit more if that
happened to me what would you do I would
I would become like Jesus just walk on
water straight out of there you know you
you got to choke hold that Gator I think
that's the only only way you gotta like
go in with the elbow drop on top of the
Gator is the only way yes I think I'm
you're not going to swim away from
it that's what I would do if anyone
pushes me into a gator pit drop
K the dog
[Music]
park
I'm just so glad it wasn't anything bad
about
women yeah there's a flashlight
Community do you did you know this K are
you kidding me like what what they like
rate flashlights no how much they blond
you it's a community of people who are
very passionate about the fact that they
have a flashlight always on them so that
once that time comes where any someone
goes hey does anyone have a flashlight
oh God what do we do music starts
playing Cape starts flowing in they win
Oh Yes actually some guy pops up behind
like yeah I have it on my
phone yeah I got one on my phone you
know whenever I want it yeah I got I got
you here you go all right well there
someone's big day finally came power
outage at the grocery store big day for
me
register on generator beam shots the
comments dude you're living the dream
the moment where you pull out the
flashlight and it makes you a hero
people almost exclusively other guys
will ask where you got it and you get to
talk about it this is your
moment like that person should being
sarcastic the why can't everything be
about this what the I never been hyped
up this much by any comment I guess just
most most of got culture right you get
like your your super cool car because
you want to ATT trct girls most guys
come up to talk to you about it you get
SW you know impress girls and mostly dud
come to ask you what your workout
routine is dude just come and slap you
on your ass yeah I know it's just tough
you like fart jokes I love fart
jokes must be a really squeaky floor
there cuz girls don't fart they don't
fart
what it's just how she laughs as you
notice it goes with her
laughing oh you're
right yeah which one's laughing and
which one's farting did you ever fart in
a Pringles bottle what what what what
what do you okay give me I'm just no no
no no no just wondering what do you do
fart in the Pringles can like if you
didn't F the Pringles can did you even
have a childhood can I I guess I didn't
what do you do eat Spam all day in the
States you have to fart and the Pringles
can why why is it not socially
acceptable to
[Music]
[Applause]
fart You Got to Believe come on
frogo come on man keep going you think
you can be psychoanalyzed based on your
memes is that a oh yeah oh yeah all
right well we're ending that video there
thank you King
so thank you for having me thank you for
sharing these memes I've been
enlightened that last one is definitely
not a representation of our job of
continuously making more and more videos
to stay
relevant oh
man I bet you're sitting here thinking I
wish I could learn something too well
you can did you know that this Discord
recently got hacked and over 700,000
users more got their user data stolen
did you know that did you know that did
you know that well you would know that
if you use nordvpn greatest VPN oh
because nordvpn is so much more than a
VPN it's your best friend it's a cool
Summer's breeze it's a pattern in the
back saying good job when you didn't
really do
anything nor VPN monitors the dark web
for you so when a website or an
application gets compromised your user
data is stolen how would you normally
know you would have to constantly look
it up I don't know constant fear and
distress but nor VPN does this for you
so you would know immediately if this is
happen and you know it's time to change
all your passwords with even more
amazing features like threat protection
which makes sure that you don't click on
any oopsies you ever clicked on an oopsy
it's not good use nor VPN so much more
than just a VPN browse the internet SA
safely the whole internet safely and
securely don't even worry about it bro
if you use the link in the description
nordvpn.com PewDiePie you get the best
deal with a two-year plan huge discount
think think big now multiply it with
huge because you also get four
additional months for free you are
welcome but you have to use my link use
my link and no other link and no other
vpns either use my link trust me I've
been using novpn for years it's an
amazing service I highly recommend it
and if you want to just check it out
it's 30 days money back guarantee check
it out what you got to lose Link in the
description